[Music]
[Music]
good evening my name is Amy Makris I'm
the coordinator of the technology and
culture forum at MIT and it's my
pleasure to welcome you to this very
special event this evening as someone
remarked when they were arriving tonight
this is a unfortunately timely event and
I'm glad that the technology and culture
forum is able to present it to you this
evening I'd like to thank our
co-sponsors for this event without whom
we could not have put this together they
are the tech the science technology and
society program at MIT the department of
political science at MIT and the
Episcopal Diocese of Massachusetts I
also want to thank a few students who
came to us in late August and put a be
in our bonnet and said you have to do
something on this topic and they were
right and they are Julius steinberger
Stephanie Wang and Eric Downes so thank
you to you
[Applause]
I also want to draw your attention to
the fact that next week the technology
and culture forum begins to series of
forums that will continue throughout the
fall one is on the politics and
Technology of motherhood and the other
is on energy the environment and global
politics and you can find out more about
both of those series by going to our
website and the website is listed right
behind me our focus that the technology
and culture forum is on addressing the
critical issues of our day and I think
that you will agree with me that the
issue that will be addressing this
evening is the critical issue of our day
simply a glance at the newspapers in the
last few weeks has made it clear that
the critical question before not just
our nation but the whole world is do we
have cause for war against Iraq and
that's going to be our focus tonight
taking a look at that question our
format is that we have a moderator who
will begin the evening by giving us an
overview of the question and the
situation at hand and then he will
introduce the two speakers both of whom
will offer their remarks and following
that we hope to have plenty of time for
questions from you and we hope that you
will feel free to ask your questions
we'll probably have some mics that we
can bring up the aisles to to get
people's questions so that you can be
heard and I'm very glad to be able to
introduce our moderator to you he is
Kenneth oi
ken is an associate professor of
political science at MIT working in the
fields of American foreign policy
international political economy
international relations theory and
Technology Policy a former director of
the Center for International Studies at
MIT he has also served on the faculties
of Harvard University the University of
California Princeton University and
Swarthmore College and he has been a
guest
scholar at the Brookings Institute he
has edited and contributed to a series
of four volumes on u.s. foreign policy
Eagle in a new world
American grand strategy in the post Cold
War era
Eagle resurgent the Reagan era in u.s.
foreign policy Eagle defiant u.s.
foreign policy in the 1980s and Eagle
entangled u.s. foreign policy in a
complex world so very happy to hand this
event over to Ken white our topic
tonight is cost for war assessing the
Bush administration's case against Iraq
it's a difficult task that we have
before us both to lay out the elements
of the Bush administration's case and to
then probe and assess point by point
some of the key assumptions some of the
logic behind their strategy we're very
fortunate indeed to have Scott Ritter
and Steve wolf to help us in this task
and I'd like to first ask you to join me
in welcoming them to MIT
they have unusual attributes or skills
that they bring to this enterprise as
most of you know Scott was the chief
inspector on Iraq between 1991 and 1998
he spent how many trips to Iraq over 50
over 50 trips going back and forth
assessing and evaluating weapons
capabilities the status of weapons of
mass destruction I should also note that
he probably had more first-hand
experience dealing with Saddam Hussein
than any and all people in this room
indeed probably most of the
administration added up together and
these attributes and skills caused him
to be an extremely useful asset as we
probe these issues this evening now
Steve wall of course comes out of the
world of the Academy and you might
assume that that would not prepare him
to adequately assess or evaluate the
difficult and controversial and
dangerous topics that we have in front
of us but I should note that in addition
to writing and he has a wonderful book
on the origins of alliances and on
revolutionary regimes in war that we'll
turn to in a second but his real
qualification for this is that Steve is
a new academic dean at the Kennedy
School of Government at Harvard
University and anyone that can survive
the interplay of conflicting forces when
you look to students and faculty and
central administration in that setting
is probably as skilled and as adept at
dealing with problems like these as
anyone in the world so I think you're
both equally qualified
although I'm not sure whose job is the
more dangerous I am now let's move into
a quick review of the issues and I don't
want to take too much time on this
because we obviously have we want to
allow time for our speakers but to set
the stage for this let's go back a few
years if you go back to 1998 at the time
when Scott was last in Iraq conducting
inspections one set of issues our
concerns is what did you know then and
how did you know it with reference to
weapons of mass destruction biological
chemical and nuclear capabilities and
even more critically and centrally from
your experiences as an inspector at that
time what can you now tell us about the
current status of Iraqi biological
chemical and nuclear systems this is now
four years after the inspections stopped
and the questions at hand here and
they're central to the Bush
administration's case against your own
are with reference to chemical to what
extent in those intervening years have
the Iraqi Iraqis managed to put together
either a small or a large chemical
weapons capability with reference to
mustard gas Colin sarin and VX okay and
they obviously have the capacity to
produce to what extent in the absence of
inspections is there reason to be
concerned in in what quantities with
reference to biological they're plenty
of dual use systems that can and are
oftentimes used and for the production
of biological agents something as simple
as fermentation and on through the
various laboratories that one could find
perhaps on the MIT campus certainly on
the MIT campus
and the question here is again given
what was going on way back in 1998 and
the capabilities that they probably have
had in the interim period to what extent
have they been able to or do you believe
that it's possible that they have
developed stabilized and weaponized
strains of biological agents with
reference to nucular it's been a few
years okay there's a pretty rigorous
regime in place externally but the issue
of the extent to which through
black-market means twenty to thirty
kilograms of highly enriched uranium
could have been obtained or whether
centrifuge technologies could have been
used for other technologies use to
separate and create fissile materials
for weapons programs at home whether
those are in your view likely or
unlikely possible or impossible
and if fissile materials are available
to what extent is a rock capable of
fashioning them into an implosion or gun
device now these technical issues and
they're largely technical issues based
in part on assessment of the status of
Iraqi economic in technical
infrastructure as well as the
credibility of external efforts to limit
access to critical sources of supply are
obviously only part of the picture the
technical concerns start us in our
evening but obviously it doesn't take us
to the answers there's also the issue of
what capabilities are and when I say
tolerable I don't mean terrible in the
sense of being welcomed but tolerable in
the sense of producing or yielding
significant security threats zero is a
very hard number to defend or justify
when you're talking about biological and
chemical and in current context with an
administration that has been focusing
oftentimes on terrorism and
unconventional threats to what extent
are relatively small quantities of
chemical or biological agents something
for the United States to fear okay now a
second big question and it's an
extremely large question centers on the
issue of inspections
the alternative or one alternative I
should say to going the war is to turn
to and rely on an updated or modified
version of the inspection regime that
Scott was part and parcel of back in
1998 and the question simply put is how
effective will inspection or would
inspection be with what levels of
cooperation on the part of two
presidents that may not be entirely
enthusiastic about inspections Saddam
Hussein was not entirely cooperative
during your last vacation periods and I
dare say that George Bush is not wildly
optimistic or enthusiastic about
inspections in this matters and it
matters because the character and the
quality of intelligence provided by the
US administration might be useful or
critical in terms of conducting
inspections in an effective way so a
second issue to Scott and to Steve is
really the extent to which inspections
present a viable means of addressing and
improving u.s. national security a third
set of issues and concerns really would
focus on economic and political
instruments okay and this is something
that isn't much discussed in current
context but we have out there in the
real world a variety of programs some of
which are underfunded and neglected that
are designed to try to advance American
security not through military means but
through other channels nunn-lugar for
example is a program that aims at
purchasing buying up securing black
market uranium and plutonium and thereby
limiting access to fissile materials
there is a sanctions regime in effect
and here I'm not talking about sanctions
against Iraqi water chlorination
equipment but limitations on access to
critical military technologies and so
one set of issues or concerns would be
the extent to which economic and
political instruments might particularly
take an in conjunction with inspection
produce a viable path to limiting or
eliminating Iraqi capabilities finally
we turn to the administration's chosen
instrument preventive war and regime
change let's sit back and examine and
talk
this let's talk about it and analyze it
in terms of upside and downside what is
the best case that they're advancing to
us that we hear day after day week after
week but also what are the downside
risks associated with turning in
relatively short order to a military
option what are the risks to American
troops what are the risk to Israel a
potential attack if in fact we succeed
in pushing Iraq to the wall
what would the Israeli response likely
be if they were attacked with chemical
or biological agents and what are the
risk to us of potential terrorists use
of small quantities of weapons in the
event that the situation spins out in
people's backs are pushed to the wall
are we talking here potentially about
the threat of terrorists use of
biological agents as a self-fulfilling
prophecy where the actions that are
undertaken by the administration yield
the result of the most dread and finally
to look beyond the Middle East to look
to the broader structure of American
foreign policy to what extent is this
new doctrine of preventive war which has
been advanced with such fervor by the
administration something which is
disturbing in terms of the precedents
that it sets for u.s. foreign policy had
we adopted or acted on these precepts or
principles toward China for example we
would have probably launched or wiped
out elements of China back in the 60s
India might well have destroyed Pakistan
but some discussions systematic
discussion of what happens should
preventive war become our doctrine and
become accepted as a principle in
international relations where does that
take us again we're fortunate that we
have both Scott with this experience and
inspection and Steve with this extensive
writings on Alliance politics a key
issue in terms of the responses and on
radical and revolutionary regimes with
insights into Iraq as our panelists this
evening Scott why don't we begin with
you and we'll go again for about 20 to
25 minutes with each and we'll go for
questions and answers afterwards I guess
out of not out of any sense of superior
I've been told I need to speak from the
okay well we're you're moving to the
podium if you wish to follow up on this
between 10:00 and 11:00 tomorrow Scott
will be appearing
the connection on WBUR we should
probably make our instance for Tom and
Ray on Car Talk to conduct the interview
[Music]
well I want to say just how appreciative
I am to have the opportunity to be here
tonight to speak with you because as
it's all too obvious we truly live in a
very dangerous time where we are
speaking about our country going to war
and you know you you've outlined some
some extremely important issues and that
need to be addressed let me start off by
explaining where I'm coming from as I
talk about this if you check out my
resume you aren't gonna find nuclear
physicist biologists chemists or rocket
scientists anywhere in that resume so I
seem to be the most unlikely of people
to sit here and talk to you today about
the technologies of weapons of mass
destruction what you will find is
intelligence officer operator leader
marine that's my perspective my
perspective was going into Iraq and
doing a task viewed myself as someone
soar like a beat cop out there on the
street
implementing enforcing the law and this
is an important concept because I think
it's going to underscore everything I'm
going to talk about tonight and how I
answer every one of your questions that
you put forward law law why do we do
what we do why was I in Iraq to begin
with because the Security Council passed
a resolution saying Iraq can't have
weapons of mass destruction that's why
now what gives the Security Council the
authority to pass that resolution the
United Nations Charter of which the
United States of America is a signatory
and what makes the United Nations
Charter so important to us as Americans
because it's an agreement that we've
entered to as a nation and our
Constitution says that when we enter
into an international agreements in the
treaties those agreements carry the
force of law here in America so I'm
coming down to the basic issue here that
underscores everything I'm going to talk
about the Constitution of the United
States of America and it has to play a
role in everything we do
visa V Iraq visa VI RAC now in 1998 what
was the situation the situation was the
international community said Iraq must
be disarmed to 100% that they can have
no chemical biological nuclear or
long-range ballistic missiles now by
1998 we had achieved a very advanced
degree of disarmament these aren't my
words these are the words of Rafa Cadiz
the Swedish diplomat who ran the program
from 1991 to 1997 he says that by 1996
Iraq had been fundamentally disarmed
that we had a counter for 95% of Iraq's
weapons of mass destruction programs and
this included all the factories and you
were used to produce weapons of mass
destruction all the associated
production equipment and the vast
majority of the product produced but the
law says 100% therefore fundamental
disarmament isn't enough according to
law it says 100% and we have to force
that issue we have to find the
unaccounted for material and that's what
I and other inspectors were seeking to
do find out the final disposition of the
unaccounted for material what was
unaccounted for
no weapons factories were unaccounted
for not that we knew of I mean you can
always throw out the hypothetical of
well Scott you say you got a mob but
what about the ones you don't know of
that's an important factor I say we got
all the production equipment well Scott
wait a minute what about the production
equipment you didn't know about that's a
good issue that's a good point and I say
that we accounted for most of the
product produced by these factories but
I just acknowledged it could be
factories and production equipment that
we didn't know about so what about the
product they produced that you don't
know about good point all the good
points now we come to one of the issues
talk about how good our inspections how
good are the inspections especially when
you care confront with the situation
that we ran into in Iraq where the
Iraqis made a decision from the very
beginning to lie about their weapons
capabilities to fail to declare entire
nuclear programs biological programs
under declare the chemical programs
under to clear their ballistic missile
programs it made the task of disarming
Iraq already a difficult task from just
a basic scientific and technical
perspective extremely difficult because
now we had to go into a nation which was
not cooperative in which was we had to
conduct operations in a hostile
environment and again this would seem to
degrade confidence in what we were able
to achieve
but I told you I'm not a physicist a
biologist chemist rocket says I'm an
intelligence officer I'm a marine I love
challenges like that and I'll tell you
what all the inspectors that work for
the special Commission we love
challenges like that too our job was to
implement the law to hold Iraq fully
accountable to the rule of law as set
forth by the Security Council that meant
that we were going to find out what
these capabilities were regardless of
Iraq's obstruction and we prosecuted the
case in that manner now I need to say
right up front that myself and the other
inspectors prosecuted the case against
Iraq not only in terms of holding Iraq
accountable to the law but ensuring that
we ourselves did not deviate from the
rule of law and doing our job I should
underscore from very start that our
mission in Iraq revolved around
disarming Iraq's chemical biological
nuclear and long-range ballistic missile
capabilities that's what the law said
resolution 687 the law also said that
economic sanctions imposed on Iraq in
August 1990 when they invaded Kuwait and
continued through at resolution 687 in
April 1991 were linked to the lifting of
which were linked to Iraq's compliance
with its obligation to disarm that if
Iraq was found to be in compliance these
sanctions would be lifted that's the law
you will not find any law in terms of a
Security Council resolution that talks
about regime removal you simply will not
furthermore you will find that the
concept of regime removal is in itself a
violation of international law as set
forth by the United Nations Charter
which clearly states that no nation has
the right to pick the leadership of a
sovereign state that is the sole
prerogative of that nation regime
removal is not part of these resolutions
and yet from the very beginning as this
beat copy out they're doing my job in
trying to hold Iraq accountable for the
law our process of investigation was
corrupted by the fact that the United
States had a policy of regime removal in
place from the very beginning the United
States a member of the Security Council
who passed this resolution went on
record through their second then
Secretary of State James Baker in 1991
who said even if Iraq complies with its
obligation under international law or
under under international law to disarm
economic sanctions will never be lifted
until which time Saddam Hussein is
removed
so from the beginning we didn't have
just obstruction on the part of Iraq but
we had this inherent pollution of the
process of investigation imposed by my
own country the United States of America
which said that we don't care what the
law says we're gonna hold Iraq
accountable to a different standard a
standard that is unilateral in nature
which deviates from the rule of law
this complicated our process as well
imagine me and other inspectors stand
before the Iraqis and saying you have to
comply you have to comply and they said
why we're damned if we do damned if we
don't it complicated our task it
complicated the integrity of the process
of investigation but we still did a good
job we broke through the walls of Iraqi
deceit we brought to bear the powers of
determination intelligence science and
just darn good police work and breaking
through and finding out what the Iraqis
had let's understand when we talk about
weapons of mass destruction we're not
talking about a magic show you don't
pull the weapon of mass destruction out
of thin air like you do a white rabbit
to have a black hat at a magic show it
just doesn't work that way
weapons of mass destruction are a
product of Science and Technology you
don't prove to produce them in a hole in
the ground you don't produce them in a
basement you produce them in an
industrial facility
now these injustice villages can be
small they can be big whatever but there
is science and technology involved they
have to procure equipment the Iraqis
have to procure equipment that means
there's a trace of this procurement
effort they have to have scientists who
work on the equipment that is also a
piece of evidence that can be
investigated what I'm getting at here is
that through the process of a detailed
forensic investigation similar to what a
policeman would do at a crime scene
we were very capable of cutting through
Iraq's to see through their lies I'll
make a statement of fact after the
summer of 1991 weapons inspections never
found a single weapon of mass
destruction in Iraq never found one and
yet Scott you say he just said you had
fundamental disarmament 95 percent
accountability we got to where we got in
regards to accounting
because the Iraqis were compelled to
confess in the same manner that a
criminal confesses to a police officer
when confronted with overwhelming
evidence we went to Europe the nations
that sold Iraq this technology we got
the bills of lading the letters of
credit
we got the invoices and we confronted
the Iraqis with these and they had to
confess
having capabilities that they had denied
having we confronted them with the
inconsistencies in their testimony in
there when we would interrogate them for
hour after hour we confronted with the
inconsistencies until they were
compelled to confess we blanketed Iraq
with inspectors equipped at the highest
technology who went forward and
collected forensic evidence which was
used to confront the Iraqis and compel
them to change their story in this
manner we got Iraq to admit having a
nuclear weapons program although they
said they'd ever had one in this manner
we got Iraq to admit having a biological
weapons program although I say they
never had one this manner we got Iraq to
admit having advanced chemical weapons
capability VX nerve agent although they
said they never had one in this manner
we got Iraq to admit that it had
indigenous ballistic missile
manufacturing capability although they
said they never had when ladies and
gentleman we did a good job as
inspectors we did a darn good job not
good enough though the law said 100
percent and 95 percent didn't hack it
and at the end in 1998 we were
attempting to achieve that final closure
on that remaining 5% but understand what
we're talking about here unaccounted for
material not retained material you will
not find a single United Nations
document pertaining to weapons
inspections it says that Iraq retains
prohibited capability our Iraq is known
to preteen a weapon of mass destruction
we have documents that say that we
cannot account for everything but
because we can't account for it or can't
account for it does not automatically
translate into retention on the part of
Iraq big difference and you mitigate
this further when I tell you that from
1994 to 1998 weapons inspectors in Iraq
monitored with the most intrusive
capable on-site inspection regime in the
history of arms control monitored Iraq's
industrial infrastructure 24 hours a day
seven
a week with no notice inspections remote
camera sensors etc and we never once
detected retained prohibited capability
or efforts by Iraq to reconstitute so we
had Iraq pretty much bottled up there
was unaccounted for material which is of
great concern but we had put an umbrella
of monitoring inspections over Iraq
which meant that if they ever tried to
do something with this on the counter
material the likelihood of our detection
was quite high quite high and yet that
wasn't good enough and the reason why
that wasn't good enough that I come back
to the concept of the pollution of the
integrity of the process because the
United States didn't care about the
disarming of Iraq the United States
cares about the elimination of Saddam
Hussein from power and that the
inspection process is only convenient to
the United States insofar as it
facilitates the containment and
destabilization of Saddam Hussein
leading to his removal from power but
the second the inspection regime starts
to come up close to that concept of
compliance it becomes a threat to the
United States because compliance means
that economic sanctions have to be
lifted compliance mean that containment
is broken compliance mean that Iraq
comes back to the full of the
international community was Saddam
Hussein still at the helm which of
course is the last thing the United
States once so the United States killed
the inspection process by using the
inspectors to deliberately provoke a
crisis that led to the triggering of a
military action Operation Desert Fox in
December 1998 which then went after
Saddam Hussein using data collected by
the inspectors about the security of
Saddam Hussein we were there to collect
out about weapons of mass destruction
not the security of Saddam Hussein the
American government ordered the
inspectors out two days before they
began bombing Iraq in December 1998
there's a lot of Mythology out there too
somehow the Iraqis kicked the inspectors
out think again the United States
ordered the inspectors out in Iraq has
said the inspectors are not welcome to
return and they haven't been there for
four years so now comes the question
what is transpired in those four years I
told you there's a lot of concern about
unaccounted for capability frankly
speaking don't worry about that for
people to point back and talk about
Iraq's anthrax capability and say
because we couldn't account for
everything and night
91 on they have an anthrax capability
today this is false
Iraq produced liquid bulk anthrax the
factory the producer was eliminated and
even if they held on the liquid bulk
anthrax within three years it germinates
and becomes sludge so the only way Iraq
could have anthrax today is if it
reconstituted a manufacturing base since
the time inspectors left since December
1998 can they do that yes they have
inherent indigenous capability that can
be reconfigured to produce small amounts
of biological agent should we be
concerned yes very concerned Chemical
Weapons we destroyed the huge Mathon
estate establishment and other chemical
facility that were used to produce
chemical weapons Iraq did not have a
capacity in 1998 to produce chemical
weapons thanks to the inspectors you
remove the inspectors Iraq when the
period of two weeks can reconstitute a
mustard production capability Iraq
within a period of two months can
reconstitute a sarin and Tabu nerve
agent production capability Iraq within
a period of four to six months can
reconstitute a VX nerve nerve agent
production capability should we be
concerned yes
very concerned nuclear weapons
completely different proposition we
eradicated Iraq's ability to enrich
uranium eradicated it and for Iraq to
reconstitute a tree require an
investment of time and money and react
react juez ition of technology that
frankly speaking cannot be accomplished
without detection that's that's my
assessment even if they had acquired
this to actually rebuild it and get it
up and functioning again undetected in a
manner which would produce highly
enriched uranium will take a
considerable amount of time so in terms
of an Iraqi nuclear threat and in
regarding any react juez ition of highly
enriched uranium capability production
capability don't worry about it should
we be concerned no not at this point in
time concerning Iraq's ability to
produce a nuclear device - a fissile
core ladies gentlemen they solve that
problem they had that problem solved
1991 and they have all the means and
materials today to build a nuclear
device - the fissile core so if we're
worried about a nuclear weapons
capability in Iraq we should be focused
on the concept of fissile material this
is where the nunn-lugar issues come up
how could I RAC acquire fissile material
should we be concerned about it
absolutely absolutely ballistic missiles
is another issue can Iraq do things to
reconstitute a long-range missile force
yes should we be concerned about it not
too much because the missile doesn't
work unless they test it and if they
test it we'll find out about it and to
date no one has detected a test of a
long-range ballistic missile so minimize
that concern but we should be very
concerned about a biological chemical
and nuclear capability in Iraq today
inspectors haven't been there for four
years now the question is does this
concern translate into a cause for war
do we go to war because we're concerned
about Iraq having this capability I
would say to you that if Iraq continued
to refuse to allow inspectors to come in
we would have more reason to be
concerned and more reason to consider
the prospect of military action to bring
to an end this issue of Iraq's weapons
of mass destruction but that has all
been mooted by the fact that Iraq has
recently said we will allow for the
unconditional return of inspectors and
give them unfettered access do I believe
they will no but it doesn't matter what
I believe they're on the hook they've
committed and there's not going to be a
second chance this is it
Saddam's used as nine lives so now when
I talk about biological weapons chemical
weapons and nuclear weapons that are of
great concern and I share this concern
how do we resolve this issue short of
war and I would put forward that sending
inspectors back in especially given the
record of effectiveness that the
inspectors had from 1991 to 1998 in
disarming Iraq is the best venue to come
to closure on the weapons inspections
issues we were the best forensic
investigators the world has ever seen if
Iraq has done some
thing of a prescribed nature and the
four years since inspectors been out
I'll put my reputation on the line to
say we'll find it
we'll find trace evidence of it that
they couldn't hide every trace so let's
get inspectors in and give inspectors a
chance to do their job because it does
allow us a alternative to war to resolve
this issue if Saddam Hussein chooses not
to cooperate I think we would be right
to presume ill intent and therefore
treat him as a pariah leader at the head
of a rogue nation deserving of harsh
punishment from the international
community but as someone who wants to
prosecute a clean case against a
criminal named Saddam Hussein we cannot
prejudge this situation we must run a
clean investigation of Saddam Hussein
and the inspectors are the vehicle as
set forth by international law to do
this so let the inspectors in let them
have their chance but in addition to
Iraq's obligation to disarm to do what
the world community says to be held
accountable to law we must likewise
understand that the previous inspectors
have been corrupted they're bad cops
can't trust them can't trust the
inspection process what are we going to
do to ensure that future inspectors
don't again deviate off course the first
thing is to address the issue of regime
removal this American policy of regime
removal what's its legality
what's its viability how does it damage
the issue of the arms control because if
the United States still promotes a
policy of regime removal above
disarmament than ladies and gentlemen I
would tell you that the issue is in
Iraq's weapons of mass destruction or
any threat coming from their weapons of
mass destruction the issue is rather the
ideology behind the concept of regime
removal to begin with an ideology that
has been further defined by an American
national security strategy document put
out last week which talks of
unilateralism American unilateralism I
would say that Iraq is the case study
the case the first case study for
implementation of this policy of
unilateralism and this has to calm the
question everything we just talked about
because
going to war with Iraq if it's about the
threat posed by Iraq about the threat
posed by weapons of mass destruction
then shouldn't we give inspections a
chance to resolve that if we're not
willing to give inspections a chance
then why are we talking about going to
war what is the threat posed by Iraq
these are questions I think have to be
asked have to be addressed especially
when we consider our role as American
citizens and I'll bring up as I close
the concept of the Constitution in the
United States of America where our
nation of laws where our nation of laws
we the people of the United States
cannot sit by while our government
implements a policy in our name which
operates outside the framework of law
and I'm afraid right now in talking
about Iraq that is indeed what the case
is thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
that was terrific I feel a little bit
sheepish or guilty being here because
this event has been co-sponsored by at
least two institutions that I've
disappointed in my life the first is MIT
because MIT first admitted me to
graduate school and I went to Berkeley
instead and then the political science
department offered me a job and I went
to the University of Chicago instead the
other institution is the Episcopal
Church in which I was raised and let's
just say my attendance for the past 27
years hasn't been very high despite my
misgivings delighted to be here because
I'm delighted to see people taking this
issue as seriously as they are I think a
nationwide and especially in Washington
the absence of real debate on what we're
up to as a country has been quite
striking despite the importance of this
issue
it this is not the sort of decision we
should make blindly but that we should
stumble into or that we should be led
into by a rather small cabal within the
administration and I want to lay out
sort of why I think that's it's not a
bad idea as briefly as I can let me
start by just making it clear you know
my biography or at least where I come
from I am NOT a pacifist in the
international relations world
I'm regarded as a realist I think the
world is in fact a nasty dangerous place
and that sometimes using military force
even in large quantities is justified so
in some circumstances I think it's the
right thing to do but I don't think it's
always the right thing to do always
prudent and always in our best interest
and it should never be used casually or
carelessly and let me lay out one other
sort of introductory point and then I'll
lay out why I think it's not a good idea
in this case the overarching point I
want to make to all of us here is
basically an argument about humility
I believe and I'll say why in a moment
why I think a war against Iraq is a very
bad idea but we all ought to start by
recognizing we could be wrong about this
war itself is inherently uncertain and
it's possible that a military campaign
would go very well it's possible the
cost would be low for us and for Iraqi
society it's possible that after such a
war Iraq would stabilize rather quickly
a reasonably effective and just regime
might emerge it's possible that that
would trigger reform throughout parts of
the Arab world
it's possible that the rest of the world
would see this display of American
principle and power and then be even
more willing to help us fight terrorism
or other things and it's possible of
course that this would also hasten the
settlement of the israeli-palestinian
struggle on fair terms I can't I can't
be certain that all of those things
won't happen it's also possible and I
mean this sincerely it's possible that
not acting now could lead to something
very bad it's possible that he might get
say a nuclear weapon at some point in
the future and then do very bad things
with it
so all of those things are possible but
there's a lot of uncertainty about all
of those things I just said and our task
as citizens is to use what we know and
use our reason to try and figure out
what we regard is most likely what the
alternative courses of action are
reasonable people may disagree about
some of these issues but we all ought to
start by recognizing we could be wrong
all right we don't know all right now
having said that let me lay out in my my
views on why I think it's a bad idea the
debate here is not about whether Saddam
Hussein is an evil man evil leader or
whether Iraq has defied prior UN
resolutions I thought the President's
speech in the United Nations was very
convincing on both points he's a bad guy
and he's defied the UN I'm convinced but
this is not news right most governments
and most people around the world I think
probably share that view neither point
makes him unique and the real question
right the real question before us
is whether going to war with Iraq is the
best thing to do right now in other
words is it in our national interest
will it leave us better off in the
future than we are today
do we have alternatives that look better
I think we do so I'm gonna give you 6
big reasons why it's a bad idea
reason number one there is no credible
evidence of a link between Iraq and
al-qaeda there have in the last 48 hours
been a couple of fresh accusations one
from Donald Rumsfeld and one from
Condoleezza Rice suggesting that in fact
there is a link we've got the goods now
the timing of this revelation is
somewhat suspect and the word that
people love to use now is link right
that there's a link between al-qaeda and
Baghdad well there are links between the
United States and every government on
the planet
they're called diplomats they meet all
the time all right link is a very vague
word what you'd be looking for is
deliberate and willful and active
cooperation right between these two
things and no credible evidence has yet
been presented I regret to say that more
governments that want to go to war are
often very good at putting things
together and fabricating things and
unfortunately if you look at American
history the American government
Democratic and Republican are no
exceptions there all right governments
do lie or governments convince
themselves that they have evidence when
they really don't so no link between
Iraq and al-qaeda and boy have they
looked for it reason number two even if
Saddam Hussein had large quantities of
weapons of mass destruction and even if
he got a nuclear weapon down the road
sort of worst case he could not use them
without triggering massive American or
conceivably Israeli retaliation that's
why he couldn't use them as some fear to
intimidate others or as an umbrella for
conventional war we can defeat any
conventional force he could possibly put
in the field today any threat he might
have to escalate all right use this
handful of weapons he might get would be
deterred of
course by our threat to retaliate
they're still not usable and remember we
have a pretty good track record of
deterring other murderous tyrants in the
past Joseph Stalin had nuclear weapons
never did anything with them people in
the United States worried a lot that
Mouse a tongue a mass murderer was going
to get nuclear weapons and we even
contemplated preventive war in the 1950s
and the 1960s worrying about both of
those it turned out that both of those
tyrants were datura Balazs well it's
also worth remembering that Saddam
Hussein has never used weapons of mass
destruction against anyone who could
retaliate
he has always used them against people
who could be quite confident would not
so I don't see the big threat there I
don't like the idea of him with nuclear
weapons but I don't consider it a
sufficient fear to warrant going toward
today remember what Bismarck said about
preventive war it's committing suicide
for fear of death reason number three
war with Iraq could trigger serious
regional instability including by
creating a power vacuum within Iraq
itself by spilling over into the Kurdish
regions in Turkey and Iran one can
invent other scenarios for how
instability might spread and this is
it's important to remember a major
reason why the first Bush administration
didn't quote go to Baghdad unquote in
1991 they understood that that actually
might cause us more trouble in the long
run than leaving Saddam Hussein in place
as much as we dislike the Iraqi regime
taking it apart could leave us worse off
reason number four we will almost
certainly win a war against Iraq but he
does have some options right and those
options could make it much more
expensive than we think for example if
he does have any weapons of mass
destruction that he's able to use
there's no reason for him not to use
them if we
invaded his country with the purpose of
overthrowing his regime and probably
killing him in the process it's the one
circumstance where it's quite credible
for someone to use weapons of mass
destruction the most likely scenario for
any government to use such weaponry but
would be when it's about to fall when
it's about to collapse and after all if
he's as much of a bloodthirsty tyrant as
we have been led to believe it's hard to
believe he would feel restraint at that
moment second point is he has some
military options even at the
conventional level and I'm not sure what
he's planning but one obvious
possibility is simply take the troops
that might be loyal to him and there's
good reason to believe that some of them
would be put them in Baghdad and say no
one goes out and no one comes in without
a fight
that gives the United States some
interesting options we can bomb Baghdad
and let that be watched worldwide on al
Jazeera and CNN we can starve out the
population and let that get watched
worldwide or we can go in and wage urban
combat which is very difficult even for
a military as competent as ours is and
of course tends to kill a lot of
civilians if they're in the neighborhood
as well would he do it I don't see why
he wouldn't now again we may have some
clever strategy we've worked out to
defeat that problem I'm only suggesting
here is he does have military options he
might be able to use that would
complicate our efforts considerably oh
and by the way remember this is not
we've sort of sacrificed the element of
surprise here
which which means he's had a lot of time
to get ready and consider possibilities
reason number five once we win we have
no exit strategy everybody remember how
long we were going to be in Bosnia 12
months oh I'm sorry
18 months that was six years ago
and Bosnia is a very small country when
you think about it
Iraq has a history of instability right
beginning prior to the Revolution there
in 1958 then a series of coos and
revolts from 1958 to 1970 the Gulf War
itself once we had blown away part of
his ruling apparatus was accompanied by
lots of inter nation fighting between
different groups within Iraq civil
society in Iraq has been largely
decimated by his rule and as I think we
should be learning in places like Bosnia
Afghanistan and a number of other places
it's much easier to get into these
places than it is to get out and putting
societies back together after a war or
after large periods of dictatorship when
there are deep divisions within the
society on both ethnic and religious
lines is not easy furthermore this is
just not a society we understand
particularly well so the belief that we
can blow the regime apart and then
design a government that will work or
pick the people that are likely to lead
it well I think is overly optimistic one
final point on this our presence in this
part of the world right helped create
al-qaeda in the first place and do we
really want to increase the long term
American military presence in large
chunks of the Arab and Islamic world my
view would not if we can help it and
that leads me to reason number six a war
on Iraq will distract us from the more
serious challenge of al Qaeda we're
already not very popular in this part of
the world as I just mentioned some of
the regime's there like us at least
somewhat because we have reasonably good
relations with them but a lot of the
people don't for a variety of
complicated reasons beating up another
arab state is not gonna help and
military force remember is a crude
instrument you always hit some things
you didn't mean to hit you always have
accidents you always have some people
who don't quite get the word and the
victims of our mistakes tend not to say
oh that's alright alright we understand
all right staying there for a long time
won't help and this this rather
bellicose enthusiasm for using American
power is not gonna make the rest of the
world particularly happy either you know
they may go along because we are the
800-pound gorilla and we're pretty hard
to stand up to we can twist a lot of
arms as you've been seeing for the past
several months but I think it's
instructive to compare 1990-91 the first
Gulf War or for that matter the war over
Kosovo with our situation today in 1991
it was relatively easy not entirely easy
but relatively easy for the United
States to assemble a large diverse
coalition a coalition that in fact
included a whole bunch of countries you
wouldn't have expected to be joining us
why because he had clearly committed
aggression and lots of other countries
shared our perception that he had to be
dealt with in military terms now we're
having a great deal of difficulty doing
it right we're having to twist a lot of
arms we're having to invent a lot of
stories we're having to put a lot of
pressure on lots of different countries
and if you look at what happened in
Germany right a very loyal ally for 40
or 50 years a country that backed us up
in the war over Kosovo the Green Party
backed us up over the war in Kosovo
right and suddenly a couple of weeks ago
German politicians realized they could
improve their electoral chances by
distancing themselves as much as
possible from Washington DC all right
that should be a warning sign
that there's gonna be a giant rift
between us and the rest of the world but
the rest of the world is not happy with
the way we're behaving other than and
that's gonna undermine our efforts to
get sustained and enthusiastic
cooperation against international
terrorism moreover I don't know what
this Wars gonna cost but the estimates
have ranged anywhere from fifty billion
to a 200 billion I think 50 billion sort
of lower bound well as I look out
there's an awful lot of expensive things
we really ought to be doing all right
Homeland Security that's not gonna be
cheap if we actually take it seriously
we're currently spending about a billion
dollars a year only a billion dollars a
year to try and tie up loose nuclear
material one of the sources of fissile
material that Saddam Hussein would love
to get his hands on all right a billion
dollars a year trying to tie up loose
nuclear material in the former Soviet
Union and yet we've got 50 billion
dollars to go spend on a war with Iraq
it'll make it very difficult to get
adequate funds for that program
what about stabilizing Afghanistan so
that al Qaeda doesn't come back there
and for that matter what about helping
Pakistan
hold itself together a nuclear-armed
country where al Qaeda is where there
may be fundamentalists in the government
if Musharraf falls do we really know do
we want to spend fifty to two hundred
billion dollars knocking off Saddam
Hussein if we can't work to try and
stabilize Pakistan moreover doing
anything requires time and attention
high-level attention spending political
capital this will be an enormous
distraction
bottom line here is there is sort of a
rule of strategy you don't start a new
fight until you've finished the old one
now in fairness right the advocates of
war have a very different theory right
and I sort of articulated at the
beginning but that one sharp rap you
know knock in the front door the regime
will collapse quickly and all the other
dominoes within the region start falling
all right everything becomes easier if
we just do this but you know we've seen
this movie of time and time again of
countries who believe that there's one
short quick easy victory that will
of all of their problems if we only
defeat the Soviet Union everything's
gonna be fine the Cold War is over now
we're gonna have peace it's not the way
it seems to have worked I don't think
that's the way it would work even if the
most optimistic scenarios came true so
my bottom line here is there is no
imminent need to attack Iraq much at
risk by doing so I'm not a hundred
percent certain but the costs and risks
strike me as significant and serious war
with Iraq in a sense is a big
large-scale social science experiment
and people at MIT ought to know that
when you do a genuine experiment you
can't be sure how it's gonna turn out so
what do we do instead we maintain very
vigilant containment of Iraq which we've
done quite successfully for the last ten
years or more we use the United Nations
inspection regime as vigorously as
possible the way Scott outlined we find
as much as we can through that mechanism
and even if we don't find everything boy
we make it a lot more difficult trying
to develop and reconstitute a WMD
capability when you've got to keep
running around and dodging people like
him much much harder much much harder
fourth element of our strategy we wait
for him to die not a young man not the
world's healthiest lifestyle I suspect
and by the way that's one thing we can
predict not exactly when but we've got
we know what the upper bound is I think
and finally we focus our main effort on
defeating al Qaeda remember we do know
that there is an organization out there
that wants to attack the United States
has martyrs in it willing to die in
order to do it and it is still out there
still active and still looking for
opportunities that's the threat we
should be focusing on not saddam hussein
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
we have some microphones we'll be going
out into the audience and as we do the
question in the answer period I'd like
you to identify yourselves and kind of
where you're from as you pose the
questions I also want to note by the way
that Steve Wald is not 100% sure that
the optimistic scenario will not take
place are you 100% sure that the Red Sox
will not win the race yes
just checking and calibrating that
instrument okay let's see are there
questions and who's handling the mics
okay David Jorgensen from Somerville
this is a question for both of our
speakers tonight when I talk to my
friends and colleagues about this
looming war a lot of things that I hear
are yeah but he's a lunatic it's out I'm
a saying like this is some exception
that we need to take into account could
you guys talk a little bit how that
might affect how we deal with
international law in this particular
situation if I could just add to that
question in today's New York Times there
was an op-ed by Kenneth [ __ ] which
took that very same question that you're
opposing and spent a lot more time
making the same point but it's
effectively the same question he's a
lunatic he can't be deterred therefore
thought thought thought be very good
Scott has more experience with the man
than I do I mean I think one can make
that argue it's an irrefutable argument
right if you say that someone is
sufficiently psychotic that they can't
respond at all to any threatened
sanctions that you might put on them any
threats of punishment you might put on
them it's sort of an undefeatable
argument but we can't look at the
historical record as I alluded to there
are some pretty vivid personalities that
have had access to weapons of mass
destruction and they've used them very
cautiously that is to say not at all and
one of the reasons for that is you don't
have to be very smart or very rational
all right to realize what would happen
you if you use the weapon of mass
destruction against anyone who had the
capacity to retaliate and I have an
enormous amount of faith in that also
Saddam Hussein has blundered in a number
of occasions but he's also been I think
reasonably shrewd in remaining in power
right now thirty two years right running
a fairly despotic regime with lots of
people who probably don't like him very
much
that suggests a certain capacity for
rational calculation and planning that
could ask itself you know the question
well gee if I launched something at say
the United States or say Israel do I
think they'd retaliate and do they have
the capacity and what would happen to my
day
it doesn't require very much rationality
the same arguments were used every time
we worry about a country requiring
weapons of mass destruction and you know
knock on wood so far rationality of a
minimal sword is winning out what I'll
say is this for those who try and get in
the mindset of Saddam Hussein don't we
don't know this man we can't even begin
to understand him and I have trouble
with any American any foreigner who says
that they do know what he's thinking
that they do understand where he's at
to call him a lunatic is is
irresponsible of the on the highest
order he's not a lunatic he may be evil
but he's been around for some time now
fact that he's still in power today more
than a decade after the United States
has embraced a regime removal policy is
a clear indication that he's got
something going on upstairs I think we
do a grave disservice to our own
national security by under estimating or
oversimplifying any potential adversary
Saddam Hussein's a survivalist he's all
about the survival of Saddam Hussein and
I
just simply cannot buy into any scenario
that says that if he gained at at access
to weapons of mass destruction that he
would preemptively strike us unless of
course we had a policy of preemptively
striking him first but the bottom line
is you know I just second everything
that Professor Wald said that you he's
not an irrational person he has
exhibited a track record of rational
thinking he thinks about the world in a
way that we don't
he's a tribal leader of a very country
that's very difficult to rule and he
lives in a very difficult neighborhood
and he has to negotiate those waters and
he has done so in his way not our way
he's still in power so he does have a
good success rate I should note that the
New York Times op-ed that I was
referring to meet a specific allegation
and the specific allegation that it made
was that Saddam was saying it set up a
special Scud unit with chemical and
biological warheads ordered to launch
its missiles against Israel in the event
of a nuclear attack or a coalition march
on Baghdad is that report accurate and
if it is accurate it doesn't necessarily
mean that he's irrational does--is
suggests that we ought to or ought not
go the first of all the reports accurate
I mean I I vouch for that of that
actress because I've seen the
documentation and I led the
interrogation of the Iraqi ballistic
missile officers who revealed this the
strategy to us I believe mr. [ __ ]
also goes on to say that because Iraq
did not publicly declare this force that
it was not a force of deterrence so
rather a you know a capability to launch
a unilateral or strike that makes us
fair and I disagree with this Saddam
Hussein made it clear in April of 1990
that should Israel strike Iraq's nuclear
capability that he would burn half of
Israel with the binary weapon the binary
weapon was mounted on seven ballistic
missiles in western Iraq so I believe
Iraq did view these weapons as a weapon
of deterrence and the fact that they had
seven chemical armed weapons in western
Iraq ansan launched standby and didn't
launch those weapons his reflection of
the rash
character of this leader thanks very
much hi thank you very much by the way
extraordinary presentations take just a
little bit timeout
I'm Jonathan King I'm one of the members
of the technology and culture steering
committee for the thirty years it's been
in existence actually and I just want to
mention and to make sure you're able to
participate there's a very long
tradition at MIT
even though since World War two our
people have been involved in development
of all manner of military technology
we've also within the world of science
and engineering been in the national
leadership of the movement for nuclear
disarmament for peace the scientists
strike for peace started in MIT from
biology faculty Aaron Bernstein who's
sitting over here in Boerne fell after
the Manhattan Project launched the
bulletin the Atomic Scientists and kept
it going Phil Morrison and their
colleagues and cots ipis who were key in
the development of the nuclear weapons
freeze campaign and in the first attack
on Iraq we launched a scientist and
engineers for peace and we we mobilize
the significant group of scientists and
engineers though we couldn't we couldn't
stop it and we've decided that it's time
to revive that and so we're reviving
scientists and engineers for peace and
human development
there's many important mobilizations
going on many of you have signed the
University of Minnesota letter that's
passing and there are copies here in the
audience and you can sign it online but
we think that there's a group of people
they work in the computer industry they
work in the biotech industry they're
engineers and they don't quite have
access to the tradition of open social
action but they have some understanding
about the difference of using science to
raise people up and using science to
destroy the society so I'm just going to
circulate a a kind of petition that's
going to be the nucleus of a group that
will start here at MIT spread out
through Boston and hopefully across the
country just three quick themes don't be
a bystander pass it on to your
colleagues at Genentech or
computer technologies or Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute and three Collier
US Congressmen Coe US senator and call
your state representative and call your
state senator and call your local
elected officials and let them know
where you stand so they're stapled to
red and I'm supposed to pass this to
somebody okay
could we move to the next question I'm a
sophomore at MIT
I'd like to ask both of the speakers do
you think that the US could be perhaps
persuaded into reconsidering their
policy of regime change in Iraq and if
so how
okay I'm by nature an optimist so I'd
like to think so and I suspect you know
if they are unable I mean you think
there are a couple of things that that I
met let me start over I do not believe
the current American administration is
going to abandon that goal at any point
right that they will still favor a
policy of regime change if they turns
out that they are unable to get the
domestic and international stars to line
up in a way that allows them to use
military force I believe they will still
attempt to promote regime change there
and it's worth remembering right this
policy is not unique to the Bush
administration this has been our policy
for quite some time the first Bush
administration had it and it was the
policy of the Clinton administration as
well next part is not a partisan issue
but I don't think the Bush
administration is gonna give it up I
think we're gonna continue to press it
they may decide not to go to war at this
point if they can't get quite the right
set of political conditions or if
there's a sufficient degree of you know
domestic political reservation if it
turns out the Democratic leadership
continues to grow some backbone which
I've seen signs of in the last couple of
days it's possible that it'll slow off
but I wouldn't bet you know much on it I
would say first of all I don't want the
Bush administration to adopt a policy of
opposed to regime change
I want regime change in Iraq it's just
the methodologies that need to be
re-examined you see regime change
doesn't have to come at the point of a
bayonet or from a bomb from above we the
problem with the way the Bush
administration is formulated regime
change is that they focused on an
individual named Saddam Hussein which is
just a fantastic concept since Iraq is a
nation of 23 24 million people to try
and quantify that nation as diverse as
it is and the percentage of one man
Saddam Hussein regime change has to be
about changing the internal dynamic of
Iraq so that it doesn't produce a leader
like Saddam Hussein and that's not going
to happen
trying to impose american-style Western
liberal democracy on Iraq it's only
going to happen when Iraq undergoes the
kind of internal changes where it will
evolve as a nation-state to the point
where it doesn't have someone like
Saddam and the best way to achieve
regime change is to lift economic
sanctions against Iraq and return
control of the Iraqi economy to the
Iraqi government so that they can seek
to do things such as privatized industry
which the bath party has said must
happen if the economy is to reconstitute
it be reconstituted when you privatize
industry something amazing happens not
only do Saddam Hussein's cronies get
rich and we know that will happen but
you will develop a viable middle class
and I'm not an MIT student but of just
simple marine but I do know and studying
the the the the you know the history of
democracies one of the basic building
blocks in democracies is the existence
of a viable middle class so I want a
policy of regime change
I just opposed the tactics let's move to
this side for the next question okay my
name is Charlie Welch and my question is
basically there are being there are
weapons of mass destruction in the area
being used right now they're the
sanctions
they're killing 5,000 people a month
that and then maybe an old figure and it
might not be absolutely precise but it's
young old people in Iraq are dying
because we are not allowing the supplies
for the water conditioning systems and
all the other things that keep a basic
society running and the question is what
are we going to do about it as an
American citizens yeah here I think I
disagree in part I think we set up along
with our partners in the United Nations
mechanisms by which Iraq could in fact
get much more of what it needed to keep
the economy you know running in a way to
avoid the human cost of the sanctions
and here I think the blame does let rest
with Saddam Hussein that that he has
sufficiently perverted I guess the
oil-for-food program and others that and
kept much of that traffic for his own
purposes I want to hold him responsible
for those deaths as well not put all the
blame on the outside world
I couldn't agree more in this way first
of all come back to the cuts out I'm a
pretty simple person I have you this
like a beat cop would view it what
happens when you have a situation where
like in sanctions all these people are
dying and there's a lot of people
whatever the figures are some figures
say 300,000 some say 1.5 million bottom
lines a lot of people have died in Iraq
as a direct result of economic sanctions
who's the blame Saddam Hussein Saddam
Hussein holds the key to solving this
problem but put on my beat cop hat you
know if picked you you guys you go off
and right around Cambridge and you stop
off at a bank somebody's at the wheel of
the car the other one goes into the bank
robs the bank pops to tell her pops the
guard kills them both gets back to the
car drives off who pulled the trigger
the guy who killed him who's accountable
for murder
both people we have a situation here
where Saddam Hussein is the triggerman
he's killing the people of Iraq but you
know who else is accountable under the
law for the deaths of these people we
the people of the United States of
America why because we have imposed a
policy of economic sanctions that we
know kill people we know it kills people
and we know that it doesn't affect
Saddam Hussein and we have said these
sanctions will continue regardless of
the mechanism for lifting sanctions so
we are accountable under law as well so
I hold my government I hold you because
remember we are government of the people
by the people for the people
we're the government you're the
murderers as well I'm the murderer every
one of us who calls ourselves an
American citizen is a murderer and we
share the guilt for the death the Iraqi
people so what do we do to solve this
problem we apply international law which
says get the inspectors back to work in
Iraq complete the task of disarmament
and lift the economic sanctions but we
also have to understand that economic
sanctions we got it we got a problem
here we imposed sanctions on Iraq for
the purpose of creating suffering so
that we can pressure Saddam to do
something we want then we recognize
afterwards that the suffering is
happening but Saddam's not changing so
what do we do we put oil-for-food
resolution on to alleviate the suffering
my god what a stupid way
do business have sanctions that cause
suffering and other resolutions to
alleviate suffering why not just get rid
of the sanctions altogether
we don't need sanctions to disarm Iraq
it's a bad policy and it should be done
away with as soon as possible
[Applause]
a point of clarification on this the
sanctions imposed against Iraq have a
number of components one part consists
of restrictions or restraints on
importation of equipment of genuine
military significance okay
another component until recently were
prohibitions or restrictions through
refusal to grant licenses for equipment
that isn't of military significance
chlorination equipment for example to
purify the water supply question that I
have really takes us back to sanctions
and to your views on them when you say
that you're opposed to sanctions in this
larger sense are you opposing let's call
them legitimate sanctions that limit
access to military capabilities or are
we talking about perhaps throwing away
those elements of a sanctions regime
that are in fact killing innocent people
no there's been a modification or
adjustment in the regime in ways the
sanctions regime not the Iraqi regime
that may have diminished somewhat the
effects of sanctions on the innocence
what's your read on the change in
sanctions policy announced a couple
months ago okay well first of all let me
let me address it this way I'm my big
concern basically revolves around the
sale of oil and the income generated
from the sale of oil and the Iraqi
government's ability to take that income
and go out and procure the material
needed to run a modern society and right
now Iraq doesn't have that cave now
there's some sanctions in place that
give Iraq the ability to get you know
certain certain commodities in but we
have the 661 Committee which America
sits on we've we hold up a lot of
contracts smart sanctions are in place
today smart sanctions are designed
allegedly to help the Iraqi people get
more of what they need but we should
understand the politics of smart
sanctions smart sanctions are really
nothing more than a diplomatic
smokescreen designed to get the
humanitarian monkey off America's back
so we could focus on going to war
against Iraq without a bunch of you well
richer's and tree huggers getting in the
way
so we say we have smart sanctions we're
helping the Iraqi people get away we're
gonna go to war the fact is you know
what the best sanctions are for Iraq the
best sanctions are resolution seven one
five which is the ongoing monitoring and
verification regime there's a huge annex
at the end of it which restricts
technologies related to weapons of mass
destruction the best sanctions are
resolution 1051 which again has an annex
on controlled material it governs how
Iraq can export an import material of a
sensitive nature of thick annex the
beauty of these two is that both are the
law the Security Council has passed
these and Iraq has accepted them and
they were successfully implemented until
inspectors were kicked out so again we
don't need economic sanctions we don't
need to continue punishing the people of
Iraq we can actually turn control of
Iraq's economy back to the Iraqi
government because we have a sanctions
regime in place called ongoing
monitoring and verification that will
prevent Iraq from acquiring the
technology needed for weapons of mass
destruction and control that technology
which could be converted for weapons of
mass destruction through the process of
weapons inspections I just second that
note that note the distinction here
though it's the distinction between
sanctions that are designed to deny a
capability for example the United States
had various trade restrictions on the
Soviet Union throughout the Cold War
designed to prevent them from getting
you know advanced computers and a
variety of things that we thought were
possible a possible military use that's
very different than sanctions imposed
for the explicit purpose of coercing or
compelling a government into altering
its policies I do want to draw a sharp
distinction there which is what Scott
just did yes
I'm sorry about that
my name is Taylor Strickling I'm a
senior in political science here at MIT
this is for both the speakers I happen
to agree that I feel that you know our
standard system of deterrence will be
quite effective against saddam hussein
and i also believe it's quite suspect
that did these allegations of links
between or cooperation between the iraqi
regime and al-qaeda whether or not they
exist my question then is since that
seems to be the most compelling reason
to me for going ahead with any sort of
preemptive action what do you see as the
probability that some hussein might
decide to pursue such transfer of arms
of weapons of mass destruction to groups
such as al-qaeda or other terrorist
groups that might through other means
decide to use them
even if we can't deter him directly
that's a great question to raise it's an
important concern that's often used to
justify it I don't think it's very
worrisome again you can never be sure
what someone will do but first thing to
recognize is bin Laden and al-qaeda have
a very very different agenda then Saddam
Hussein has Saddam Hussein is a secular
individual not a religious leader at all
right Osama bin Laden has declared war
on secular regimes throughout the Middle
East all right in addition to us all
right so that they don't have any real
ideological agreement and what
occasionally worries me is that we may
in fact be providing them with the
reason for collaborating that never
existed before after all they're both on
our hit list what do you expect them to
do you expect them to join forces if
they can help each other out but just a
couple of other reasons if Saddam
Hussein has worked incredibly hard over
a 20-year period right to get a hold of
a handful and that's all we're talking
about a handful of weapons of mass
destruction first thing he does with him
is to hand them off to somebody else who
might use them in a
he can't control and furthermore where
he knows the fingerprints might come
back to him we're not a very nice
country and if someone ever did in fact
detonate a weapon of mass destruction on
American soil I don't think we would be
particularly restrained about responding
tonight I and I think that's known all
right so if you're sitting off the same
do I really want to take this very rare
thing I've got hand it off to someone I
don't like whose agenda is entirely
different than mine in the hopes that
they'll use it at a time and a place
that I'll approve of and yet no one will
ever suspect I might have done it you
know maybe but I don't think it's very
likely the Red Sox will be the key is
the Red Sox are gonna play the Cubs in
the World Series and both teams will
lose I have to second everything that
Professor wall just said and I'll throw
in my own experiences on this is through
my my work as an inspector I had the
opportunity to basically gain access to
almost every sensitive site in Iraq
including their intelligence services in
particular one organization called m21
Directorate m21 which is the Special
Operations Directorate that's a
euphemism for political assassination
and terror and I am probably the only
American who is seeing these documents
the documents of assassination the
documents of terror where they you know
we talk about Saddam being a state
sponsor of terror and here's the here's
the proof
here's Iraq who has an organization that
has plans for going into Iran and
blowing things up they have plans for
going into Kurdistan and blowing things
up they have plans to go into Syria and
blow things up to go into Turkey and
blow things up they have plans of going
around the world and killing opponents
of Saddam Hussein so on the one hand we
know that he has is this kind of
capability to export
and we should always be alert to that
fact the other thing that this m-21 did
has had plans to go in and destroy
Islamic fundamentalists in Iraq and
elsewhere and I want to highlight that
point because Osama bin Laden is an
Islamic fundamentalist terror Brist
who has nothing in common with Reich in
fact Iraq is at war with Islamic
fundamentalism another document I saw is
an Iraqi law for the security services
that says it's the automatic death
penalty for anybody proselytizing the
name of Wahhabism inside Iraq Wahhabism
of course being the sect of Islam that
is espoused by Osama bin Laden
so my experience with Iraq is not to
minimize they were potential for terror
I understand the real potential for
terror but to say that the likelihood of
Saddam Hussein cooperating with a terror
organization like al-qaeda and Osama bin
Laden is minimal to none now you
mentioned the possibility though of Iraq
using weapons of mass destruction in
terrorist outlet and what I will tell
you is this as long as Saddam Hussein
has the potential of life or his
successors have potential of life you
don't need to worry about that for the
exact reasons the professor Walt just
said however if we push him to the wall
if we say you're a dead man no matter
what this is the guy who issued orders
during the Gulf War that if he was
killed they will automatically launch
seven ballistic missiles tipped with
chemical weapons against Israel
automatically they will go down in
flames if we continue to push this
policy of regime removal ladies and
gentlemen think I told you when I spoke
that Iraq can rapidly reconstituted
aspects of their weapons of mass
destruction programs I don't believe
they're doing so now because to open the
door to inspectors means you opened the
door to discovery and they know how good
we were and they know if they were doing
something we'd find trace element but if
you shut the door on inspections and you
shut the door on any resolution of this
problem that allows Saddam Hussein to
stay in power and you say we're coming
after you and if you predict it like we
have I mean this isn't a secret attack
we've
she laid out the timeline he knows
January the Bauman's gonna start if I
were Saddam Hussein
I would then reconstitute whatever I
could and Saddam Hussein has been a lot
of time the last post past months
developing links with Palestinians in
Palestine and elsewhere and I guarantee
you this if Saddam Hussein goes down
he's gonna go down take him down as many
people as possible and he will use
terrorists equipped with whatever he can
get to them including chemical and
biological weapons so it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy in a way and I
would caution against that because right
now I don't believe he has it but if we
push his back to the wall I do believe
the scenario you just laid out is going
to become reality my name is Jack
Defendor Frank from Somerville and first
just wanted to thank both speakers and
say that I'm grateful for this forum my
question to Scott is for you I think if
I have this right I saw on CNN a couple
weeks ago that you had addressed a
legislative assembly in Iraq and had
mentioned the 95 percent statistic it
seems to me that sanity if not
constitutional principle would say that
our own Congress would want to hear the
same information before declaring war on
saddam hussein so my question is is
twofold the first is what did you hope
to accomplish by addressing a body in
iraq and secondly have you been given
the opportunity to address our congress
and if not why not
okay I'll reverse that and by saying
that I've actually been ignored by our
Congress on this issue I've been pushing
for hearings for some time now and well
when the hearings came forward you know
it's not that again it's not about me
the first thing you have to understand
this isn't about me or me promoting you
know a personal agenda this is about
generating and debate and a discussion
and getting a point of view out there
and I was stiffed by Congress I was
stiffed by the Senate and I continued to
be so and I think the reason why is that
what I bring to the table is very
uncomfortable for them to consider since
there they have a foregone conclusion
of going to war that that seems to be
the policy they want to support a policy
and regime removal remember it's the
United States Congress not the Bush
administration which has passed public
law called Iraqi liberation act and the
people who signed that act are still in
Congress today so they don't want to
hear from someone who's going to argue
against that and it's because the
Congress did this because there wasn't a
way of getting this dissenting point of
view to the American public to generate
the kind of debate that I think we all
agree is necessary if we're going to
move forward on this as a nation that I
decided there's a need for dramatic
intervention and the dramatic
intervention wasn't to go make an appeal
to a democratic institution in Iraq but
rather the sees the bully pulpit at a
critical time in American history
September 8th was picked on purpose
because George Bush was picked was
speaking with Tony Blair in Crawford
Texas where they were bringing together
their war plans in that afternoon George
Bush was going to flood the American
Airways with the talking heads the
National Security vizor Secretary of
Defense Secretary of State at Center who
were going to make the case for war to
the American people then three days
later we'd have the horrible one-year
anniversary of September 11th in which
the polity then be exploited by the
politics of fear and ignorance followed
up by George Bush's presentation on
September 12 to the United Nations in
which we suddenly propel ourselves into
war and I felt there was a need to
preemptively attack this and I chose to
do so
[Applause]
and I chose to do so by going to Baghdad
in addressing the Iraqi National
Assembly not because they're democratic
and they're gonna do anything but
because that allowed you to see me on
CNN that got every media outlet in
America suddenly wanted to talk to me
and again it's not about me but suddenly
I'm there on camera able to inject the
dissenting point of view that cannot be
ignored so that's why I went to Baghdad
I think it was a good job and you know
Congress has to take a quick follow up
on that
Scott the press reports on what you were
seeing in Baghdad were not entirely
accurate
I just want to notarize that now I just
want to note that when Amy asked me to
moderate the panel I actually was
planning to ask a series of tough
questions on why you believed that Iraq
did not have biological chemical
capabilities at this time after four
years after the lag and the answer is
that that wasn't what you said but again
there has been a significant amount of
distorting in terms of the messages that
you can delivering on okay I think Scott
put his finger on it when he said that
we have a responsibility my name is John
brightly I'm a anti-vietnam war
protester and look what's happened
between we have now a repeat we have the
Gulf of Tonkin Resolution before the
Congress and we're probably going to war
let's look at these at the source of the
problem the American people don't
understand us complicity with Saddam the
UN doesn't understand that we help
Saddam when he attacked Iran why did he
why did we help him well because we
didn't like Iran well why didn't I ran
like us because we had overthrown their
government and installed the shore
I think the problem we have to deal with
is United States foreign policy I think
we have to start thinking long-term I
think we should join with we should sign
the petitions we should talk about get
regime change in Washington in 2004 of
these of the speakers but what I'd
really like to know is as an audience
are we all prepared right now to come
back again as a group and start
discussing what we're going to do how
we're going to spread the word about US
complicity the problems with u.s.
foreign policy if we don't do that I
think if I had the opportunity to come
back in another 30 30 years you would
just be in another war this war it seems
intimate it's imminent
are we going to deal with it but also
think about the very next one history of
American foreign policy we would not
agree on everything but we probably
agree on some things and I guess that my
reaction it's not really an answer but
my reaction is I'm not sure how
constructive it is to tackle the entire
spectrum of things the United States is
doing in the world because again we
wouldn't retain much unity by the time
we'd gotten to various issues I do think
on this particular issue this is one
that lots of Americans who might
disagree on a variety of elements in
American foreign or domestic policy can
unite around alright that a war with
Iraq is not in our national interest and
we can save for the next day whether we
agree about you know globalization or
our role in Latin America or our
policies towards Russia or what we're
doing with Taiwan or whatever and I
guess the instructive example is I think
people who want to influence American
foreign policy tend to pick a single
issue or two and then pound it over
over and over and over again I mean we
are a democratic society and in
democratic societies interest groups get
a lot of what they want by focusing on
particular issues and then never letting
up on those issues most people don't
care about their particular issue they
get heard and everyone else gets ignored
on this particular issue
we ought to try and have as many people
in our group and try and make it as
active as possible
and you know if we can may have some
success here then we may be able to move
on to the next item on the agenda so I
guess I don't disagree with you but I
don't want us to get too distracted
because while we're busy organizing to
revolutionize American foreign policy
we'll also be sending the troops in I I
couldn't that's such that you see we're
gonna fight about something we're gonna
figure something to fight about I think
the Red Sox is a good start but the fact
is you know I'm simple military man and
in its focus of effort focus of effort I
mean you want to go to war you want to
win a fight focus focus focus what are
we talking about Iraq focus on Iraq
focus it and here's the other thing I
want to throw out there yeah regime
change constitutionally okay that's
remember the Constitution let's have
fair elections but let's understand how
we're gonna achieve that pardon
I think he said in Florida anyway but
what I'm getting at is the the fact is
we have a vehicle for stopping this war
with Iraq and it's called the
Constitution United States of America
it's called empowering the people and I
see a lot of desire I mean I've spoken
around the country and I see a lot of
desire for peace I see an awful lot of
desire for peace I see a lot of desire
for people to do the right thing you
know what desire gets you nothing how
much will do you have where's the will
where's the will for peace what are you
gonna do when you leave here tonight
where's the willpower you got to start
challenging yourself ladies and
gentlemen because if you don't show the
will that reflects the desire we're
going to war bottom line
[Applause]
okay we have one last question
thank you I'll lead off on this because
I think this is the perfect way for
somebody with professor Walt's
experience to wrap this up and I'm not
the one to do it my my feeling is that
this is about ideology plain and simple
this is about neoconservatives who have
sat and frustration through eight years
of the Clinton administration many of
whom rejected what the first President
Bush was doing many of whom rejected the
final four years of the Reagan
administration in terms of multilateral
approach to world to solving the world's
problem those are people who have
rejected the very notion of arms control
who reject the concept of binding
international treaties who view the
United States as being solely empowered
to do whatever it wants around the world
to take advantage of our unmatched
political and military power economic
power and prior to September 11th this
was not a philosophy that's going to be
endorsed by the American public because
it rejects everything American I believe
it's not only a flagrant violation of
international law a frontal assault on
the Constitution but it's an insult to
what we stand for as a people but after
September 11th we were pretty much cowed
into submission by the politics of fear
and ignorance and this is where the
neoconservatives pounced and they've
been promoting this policy aggressively
they now articulated it in a document
and Iraq is the case study I believe
that war with Iraq is about implementing
the American unilateralis policy of
domination as articulated by the
document and the reason why they're
pushing for so quickly is that they
don't want the American public to do
what we're doing here today discuss this
issue come to grips with the horrific
reality of what this document stands for
and thereby inject the power of American
democracy to stop it
the rush for war is about pulling a
quick one on the American people
[Applause]
I agree with most of that I want to add
a little bit to it I think that and I
could develop a strategic logic for this
but one one way of thinking through this
is that the United States likes to be
able to act in the international system
with a sense of impunity we have a very
high standard we now set for our own
freedom of action and we don't like the
idea given that we're in this unusual
position of as I put it you know
800-pound gorilla we don't like the idea
of anybody being able to afford
something we might want to try at some
point down the road so the concern
remember is not just that not really
that Saddam Hussein will do something
that we can't stop because we probably
can it's that he might be able to stop
us from doing something we might like to
try right overthrowing him is a lot more
dangerous once he does have a
significant weapons of mass destruction
capabilities that's how you one element
and it sort of echoes what Scott said
there's another part and this is gonna
be much more controversial and I want to
be very clear about what I'm saying here
I think this has also been driven very
heavily by a small group of people
mostly inside the beltway some of them
in the administration some of them not
they are neoconservatives and I think
the other part of the agenda not
inconsistent with this is the belief
that Iraq is fundamentally a threat to
Israel and that that is a large part of
what inspires them some of these people
are Jewish Americans some of them are
not right this is not something that is
a Jewish conspiracy or anything like
that
but there are neoconservatives outside
and inside the administration some of
them very closely linked to the cherone
government who have worked in
collaboration with the salah your own
government in a variety of ways in the
past and they have I think been the
principal advocates of a war against
Iraq going long before going back to
before the Gulf War in fact before the
invasion of Kuwait who believed that
Iraq's acquisition of weapons of mass
destruction was fundamentally a threat
to Israel
and therefore had to be dealt with in
this again before the invasion of Kuwait
way back 10 or 12 years ago so I think
there's another dimension to this right
which never gets talked about openly
right and it has to do with the belief
that this is something that ought to be
done to enhance the security of Israel
now I think Israel has a a right to
exist and a right to exist and be very
very secure I actually believe Israel's
policies are not making Israel more
secure they are not in Israel's overall
national interests reasonable people can
disagree about this this is not about
Israeli identity Israelis Israel's right
to exist but it's not a war I want to
fight on behalf of another country this
is something the United States should do
if it's in our interest to do it not
whether it's in the interest of anyone
else all right and I think that's the
other dimension to this that is part of
what's been pushing us closer to the
brink not the whole thing by any means
but part of it as well our speakers have
done an extraordinary job this evening
our speakers have done an extraordinary
job this evening I think that Steve has
prepared himself quite nicely for his
next term as a weapons inspector in Iraq
and that Scott will make a very fine
academic dean at Harvard University
[Applause]
you